okay du hast jetzt mehr in einen trick
und dann mache ich so aus als sollte es
wurden ausdrücklich verboten
und das kann ja das kann ich auch kein
empfehlen von euch da jetzt einen seite
rein zu machen so einen kleinen pool
entspannen
hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja
leute ich hoffe natürlich jedes gut
viele freuen sich wahrscheinlich wenn er
jetzt den titel gelesen habt und auf das
video geklickt habe weil ich habe in
letzter zeit immer wieder öfter die
nacht bekommen allerdings warum kommt
man gar nichts mehr mit wisch und
irgendwelchen anderen china online shops
und so und da ich mich dazu entschlossen
habe wieder daily videos hochzuladen
also jeden tag um 19 uhr ist auch wieder
platz für ein neues format nenne ich
jetzt mal ich habe mich nämlich
letztlich irgendwann mal abends
hingesetzt und habe mir ganz viele
verschiedene ideen rausgesucht die ich
halt umsetzen möchte und habe alle diese
dinge dann auch schon bei uns bestellt
weil ihr wisst ja das dauert immer ewig
bis das ankommen ich kann schon mal kurz
sagen also die ganzen sachen es waren
insgesamt über 45 verschiedene artikel
die insgesamt über 500 euro gekostet
haben das heißt ihr könnt euch sehr auf
irgendwelche videos freuen das passt
eigentlich perfekt das wetter war die
letzten tage so gut und da dachte ich
das cool video musste auf jeden fall
jetzt starten und dann nehmen wir dieses
scheiß video heute auf und was ist los
die sonne habe ich heute noch nicht
einmal gesehen aber da kann ich jetzt
auch nichts dran ändern
ich sag ich mal kurz ich habe einen pool
bayerisch gestellt weil ich in zukunft
auch noch drei weitere parks wir haben
noch pulver chips wir haben cool wie
sagt man diese dinge wo man drauf sitzen
ganz so luftmatratzen also das tool
patches wird das coolste dann habe ich
auch noch so ganz viele verschiedene
pult ihre bestellt ich bin wirklich mal
über die qualität gespannt freut euch
drauf und ich zeige euch jetzt erst mal
kurz zum pool hier ist das ding der wird
nach köln geschäftlicher will im auto
mitgenommen und der lag halt hier rum
und meine mutter hatten aufgemacht weil
dieses papier irgendwie so gestunken hat
und hat es weggeschmissen
ich wollte noch mal zeigen also das ist
das original papier damit ihr seht das
ist wirklich von busch ist und das hier
ist der pool der hat mich glaube ich
ungefähr 80 euro kostet ich weiß nicht
mal ganz genau das wird schon jetzt
sofort wohin dann zeige ich euch nochmal
das modell was ich gekauft habe und dann
bin ich mal gespannt ob das ein
vernünftiger pullis mit dem ein bisschen
spaß haben kann
und womit ich dann auch die nächsten
paar zu diesem thema drehen kann
leute was geht ihr kennt aus meinen
alten videos ich habe euch immer erst
einmal das produkt gezeigt was ich genau
bestellt hat damit man sich so ein
besseren überblick verschaffen kann und
ich muss das ganze im nachhinein noch
mal aufnehmen weil ich eben den sound
vergessen habe deswegen ich war schon
duschen das ganze video schon
aufgenommen heute und zwar wurde mir auf
der startseite dieser pool angezeigt
hier 305 x 150 x 60 cm ist ja auch genau
der den ihr grab schon im video gesehen
habe und ich habe für den knapp 100 euro
bezahlt ich glaube bei mir war sogar nur
92 keine ahnung dass wechselt er halt
wirklich manchmal und gerade frage ich
mich oder ich ärger mich dass ich das
einfach so schnell bestellt habe weil es
zum beispiel so einer hierfür 24 euro
wäre ja viel interessanter gewesen
deswegen jetzt erstmals schon die frage
an euch soll ich dazu vielleicht auch
noch ein video machen dann zeigt zudem
daumen nach oben oder schreibt in die
kommentare
oder halt dann auch nicht weil das hier
ist ja wirklich schon ein etwas teurer
wo ich bin überrascht dass es so was da
überhaupt in diesem preissegment gibt
weil ich kenne so ähnliche modelle die
kann es ja einfach irgendwie im
supermarkt kaufen kommt anscheinend auch
hier aus den usa hat eine gute bewertung
4,4 also so sieht er aus und so sieht er
bei mir auch raus deswegen gleich lange
wir bauen sie weiter auf dann bin ich
mal gespannt ob das alles klappt und
wieder am ende aussieht letzte okay dann
würde ich sagen mein bruder ist auch
noch mit dabei hinter der kamera was
geht dann hab da habe ich ihm auch schon
länger nicht mehr gesehen und wir können
jetzt auch mal eben auch die andere
camps rutschen und wir bauen jetzt mal
zusammen auf du darfst das dann auf
posten
und ich gucke einfach zurück das hier
ist nämlich der high tech blase bei den
habe ich irgendwann mal glaube ich von
unseren oma und opa bekommt also da
würde ich auf jeden fall viel spaß
stehen oder so auf die canon will sich
mal kurz daneben legen obwohl mir das
ding ist über drei meter lang und auf
über 150 bereich glaube ich also das ist
kein kleiner pool
da können schon mehrere personen ins
land was ich mich aber gerade auch frage
da ist ja keine beschreibung weil also
oder warte mal ich habe gerade meine
mutter gefragt ob die die schon
weggeschmissen hat aber die meint aber
auch nicht weiter deswegen müssen wir
einfach ja gut da kann man ja auch nicht
so viel falsch machen
drucke mit welchem auch wills anfangen
ob mehr leute kleines update und zwar
waren es die eine pumpe zu klein und das
ventil das auch nicht perfekt aber
deswegen haben wir jetzt einen
kompressor organisiert so also wir
machen jetzt mal ein kleines zeitraffer
und blasen im pool auf und was man auch
sagen muss heute ist sonntag das heißt
ruhestörung extrem
[Musik]
dass dort wirklich ewig werde gerade den
ersten ring und dieses teil ist so
fucking laut und den zweiten ring macht
merlin let's go
[Musik]
ok nach 20 minuten oder so kam es
geschafft es ist gut dass wir so ein
kompressor hat und ich glaube sonst
jetzt noch länger gedauert man muss
wirklich sagen der pool ist schon
relativ groß
vielleicht wird sich einmal daneben
legen damit die das sehen können oder
ich lege mich dann eben viel möglich
[Musik]
nach dem okay also man muss auch sagen
das ist schon mal kein schreibt ist kein
noch so oder so material scheint auch
eigentlich in ordnung zu sein
und jetzt kommt natürlich das wichtigste
wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen wasser
rein tun und haben uns gerade dazu
entschieden noch einmal die position zu
wechseln
ok also wasser ist eigentlich auch
installiert werden mit hier den schlauch
und ich bin mal gespannt wie lange es
dauert bis das voll ist ich hoffe nicht
zu lange weil dann kann ich das video
sogar heute noch online stellen und ich
muss natürlich auch einmal probe
schwimmen berlin auch du kannst das
wasser an machen geht auch noch bisschen
mehr druck drauf machen wir noch ein
bisschen mehr
[Musik]
hättest du nur
ist
okay wir sind jetzt ungefähr eine stunde
dabei und das lied für dich schon mal
ganz gut aus was ihr aber auch
aufgefallen ist kommen wir haben an
keiner seite irgendein logo von
irgendwas also man fragt sich natürlich
immer buch kommt dieses dingen her kommt
das jetzt aus china oder weil man muss
sagen es war verhältnismäßig sehr
schnell da die anderen sachen ich habe
zwei sachen bis jetzt von den über 40
sachen die ich bestellt habe und das war
eine davon zum wirkt wir melden uns voll
ist und am nachricht bei krebs herein
man muss ich auch sagen sondern pool
aufzufüllen das unterschätzt voll von
der zeitweise so groß sieht er ja gar
nicht aus aber da passen bestimmt 1000
liter rein und bis sie voll sind also
wir sind jetzt bestimmt eine stunde mit
dem film beschäftigt dann springt jetzt
gleich aber auch mal rein also werden
jetzt mittlerweile schon halb sechs wir
haben damit um 15 uhr angefangen also es
dauert echt extrem lange das ding ist
jetzt gleich aber fertig also ich glaube
was muss bis hier
da seht ihr diese wasserlinie und dann
springe ich mal rein man muss sagen dass
es wirklich arschkalt also ich würde
maximal 16 grad sagen und heute haben
wir auch irgendwie gar keine sonne
das heißt erhitzt sich auch nicht wer
jetzt hier so entspannt 26 grad
aber da drin arschkalt und was ich am
anfang auch schon gesagt habe ich ärgere
mich ein bisschen dass es jetzt hier so
ein standard tool ist ich hab euch am
anfang mal diesen anderen tour gezeigt
den ich eventuell auch noch bestelle der
hat nur 20 euro kostet also für so
einige hundert euro
es war schon teuer glaube ich haben hier
ruhig bisschen über den tisch gezogen
oder ich mal einfach nur dumm naja gut
fehlkauf gehört auch mal dazu merlin
kommt jetzt und dann mache ich mal einen
geilen trick da rein und dann bin ich
aber auch froh wenn ich sind haben ihr
habt weil es einfach so kalt alles klar
es ist an der zeit wir haben den pool
fast voll
aber ich will jetzt auch nicht mehr
warten sonst schau ich das nicht mehr
das video heute online zu stellen und
das ja ganz wichtig jetzt jeden tag um
19 uhr schreibst du hier ein paar länder
und tragt okay du hast jetzt mit einem
trick und dann mach ich dann außer
saltus weil sollte es wurden
ausdrücklich verboten und das kann ja
das kann ich auch kein empfehlen von
euch da jetzt einen seite rein zu machen
in so einen kleinen pool nicht sagen was
du dir ein muss das ist übrigens keine
kamera
okay wir jetzt dass du mir bitte den
trick ich machen soll
doch das habe auch gleich das ja kein
trick das ist 21
[Musik]
was es entspann dich komm ich war einmal
im see schwimmen der war auch ungefähr
gleiche temperatur nicht länger
aushalten als einer halben minute oder
so hatte eine und das machen würde es
mir nun das machen aber es ist wirklich
selbst ist also ich kann es ja auch noch
einmal ran
das gute ist dann halt immer wenn man
wieder rauskommt dann ist es sehr warm
weil wenn es kalt ist und er brauche ich
eigentlich nicht erzählt logischen ich
muss sagen also wie schon jetzt öfter
wenig er glaube ich ein bisschen dass
ich diesen pool gekauft habe ich kauf
auf jeden fall noch einen anderen wenn
die bock drauf habt gebt dann doch nach
oben dann sehe ich das und ansonsten
muss ich wirklich sagen so als kleines
fazit der hat halt wirklich knapp 100
euro gekostet und das für so ein pool
ich glaube den christen hier im aldi
oder so für 30 oder oder weil sie nicht
aber was man auch wirklich sagen muss
die qualität ist in ordnung
wir haben super gutes material findet
also es wird auf jeden fall nicht billig
und so deswegen sind vielleicht 100 euro
angemessen keine ahnung schreibt mir
eure meinung gerne in die kommentare
nochmal gegen treten noch mal gegen
trainer schaut kein monster dann vorbei
da hat sie alle knie ist jetzt
eingeleitet und wir sehen uns morgen
wieder um 19 uhr da gibt es ein neues
video